[MUSIC PLAYING]
AL HAMEL: Welcome to CMP 302.
We're going to do some
benchmarking of GCE
on this-- well, GCP, but mostly
GCE since this session is
Dory-enabled.
Please save your
questions for the end,
and please use the Dory.
And it'll be moderated
after the session.
So what's in store for you?
We'll be talking first
about Perfkitbenchmarker.
Perfkitbenchmarker is an
open source project at Google
where we're trying to
make a set of tools
to make benchmarking
easy for everyone,
trying to figure out which
cloud provider to use.
Then we're going to go
over a slew of benchmarks,
probably too many data slides.
I don't know how I
got them approved.
But there's a vast
number of slides
that will show IAS
benchmarks in many ways.
Then last week, we
announced the C2.
It's an instance type
at Google for a GCE.
And I'll be comparing that
to our older N1 instance,
and we'll see if
performance is better
or if it's different on
the C2 versus the N1.
Spoilers-- slightly better.
And then I'll be
giving you a couple
of demos and some
scripts to take
home that are pretty easy to
use if you want to compare
and contrast different
instances, different-- almost
anything.
You want to slice and
dice IAS pretty easily.
OK.
What is PKB?
Like I said, it's an
open source set of tools
that we've created
to try and make
it easy to compare
the performance
of various components
of the cloud platforms.
It supports most
cloud providers.
It has on the order
of 50 different tests
that you can run to
try and get performance
data on the different providers
or the different services.
I think it's particularly
good at getting IAS.
We've started working with GCE
pretty early on this project,
and we think we hit
most of the major touch
points that people are
interested in with respect
to performance for GCE.
We also have a number
of tests for ML
which are being
added constantly.
I put more resources over
time into our ML tests.
They test all the different
configurations via GPU,
TPU, or just running on
the processor itself.
We also do database tests, some.
Database testing is
a big art, and we
are continuing expanding our
set of tests for databases.
But it's not complete
at this point.
We need-- it's a vast amount of
work to get them all complete,
but we're working on it.
And then we have
some big data tests,
so some tests that hit
BigQuery, Dataproc,
Dataflow, and a bunch
of other services,
and compare and contrast them.
But these services are a
little bit bespoke sometimes,
so comparing them can be
a little bit difficult.
But we give it a shot.
And please try it and
tell us what you think.
Some random stats about PKB--
it's a moderately
successful project.
We have a little
bit over 300 forks.
We have 1.5k watch star forks.
We get on the order of 3.7k
commits, so 4,000 commits,
and about 100 contributors
across a number of companies.
What I really get a
kick out of, though,
is quite often when I see
an industry report come out
from one of the
big vendors, and I
look at the addendum
or the appendix,
and I can see how they did
it, it's pretty common now
that I'm seeing PKB
referenced and used
as scripts to generate
their reports, which is--
it's starting to get more and
more use for benchmarking,
especially, like I said, IAS--
IAS being Infrastructure
As a Service-- so VMs,
networking, disk.
We'll go over those.
So why do you want to
benchmark the cloud?
Well, performance is usually
one of the three top metrics
that people use when trying
to decide what cloud go to.
Security obviously top of mind.
It's been in every keynote.
Very, very important.
Reliability, availability
very much top of mind.
Benchmarking-- that is
moderately difficult.
We'll talk about
that near the end.
But that's also top of mind.
But performance, or price
performance, quite commonly,
is right up there in
purchase decisions,
so it's moderately important.
The best way to get
performance data
is by doing POCs, of course.
So you take all of
your apps, you somehow
come up with some
model where you
can bundle the good
percentage of them
up with the crucial
parts that you believe.
You move them up to the
cloud, and you run that.
The problem with POCs is
that they're quite expensive,
and they're very-- they're
just complicated/expensive.
So they're the
best but expensive.
Is there something you
can do beforehand, maybe
kick the tires, that's cheaper?
Yes.
Especially, like I said, IAS--
the models are pretty simple
for figuring out how IAS works.
I guess.
IAS is unbelievably complicated
underneath the hood.
But from a user's
perspective, when
you think about performance
characteristics,
it's not overly complicated.
So we can come up
with a bunch of tests
that allow people to compare.
And we'll see a bunch of this.
And it's moderately
easy and inexpensive.
So we're going to be hitting
five main metrics on IAS.
Boot time-- it's a weird one.
I know at first you're going
to wonder why boot time.
I'll go into why boot
time is important.
After that we'll
talk about compute.
VMs are the dominant expense
for almost every person
who uses cloud.
And what you do on VMs
is generally compute.
That's probably, in many ways,
the most important metric.
Memory-- a little bit
of a fringe metric,
but it can show you
sometimes some interesting
characteristics.
And again, incredibly
easy to run
and moderately
easy to interpret,
so might as well kick the tires.
Networking-- the VMs are
in the cloud networking.
Sending bytes, receiving
bytes is what they do.
Incredibly important.
Depending upon the app,
it could be crucial.
Many compute apps are
actually latency bound.
And if you do a lot
of HPC in the cloud--
there's a number of reasons
why networking is important--
serving.
So incredibly important, and
actually shockingly complex.
From our perspective,
again, we're
just going to do
performance, but there's
so many ways to
slice it, as we'll
see as I inundate you
with slides and data,
that there's a lot to compare
when it comes to networking.
And finally, remote
block devices or disks--
you need to boot your machines.
You've got to fetch
data from somewhere.
It's either from
usually cloud storage
or from your block device.
Pretty important
in some scenarios,
especially databases
where databases
hammer the remote block
device incredibly hard.
And knowing how the
block device responds
under this kind of hammering
for databases especially,
but all kinds of
solutions, be it
NoSQL databases or
traditional databases,
remote disks can be right
front and center with respect
to how your overall
app performs.
So benchmarking remote
disks is pretty important.
All right.
Boot times-- like I said, kind
of a weird way to start with.
You think compute,
so why boot times?
Well, the first thing is the
customer's first experience
when they get onto the cloud.
I have a really quick story
about this that I find funny.
A friend of mine
has an ML startup.
He's doing moderately well.
He's on some cloud provider.
And another cloud
provider came in
and gave him sufficient
credits to run all of his apps
for two years.
So as CEO and the guy who is
responsible for the finances,
he was totally bought in.
And he told his devs, we're
moving to this other cloud.
The other cloud had not the
best boot times in particular,
actually.
There were a number
of other issues,
but boot times really
irritated the devs.
It irritated them so
much that somehow--
and I still don't know how this
is possible-- they rebelled
against the CEO, and they
stayed with their other provider
where they were paying money.
To this day, both he and
I are incredibly confused
how this all played out.
But it's an amazing story
as to why boot times are
moderately important.
As VM lifetimes shorten--
just rationally, as
VM lifetimes shorten,
the boot time becomes
more and more important.
And I'm going to
show some data--
both how, internally, when we
view all of your workloads,
how long you keep
machines up, and then
we'll show how internally, for
us, how long we keep machines
up, and then aspirationally,
where we think
we should go on that.
And finally, it really
does show-- boot time
shows technical excellence.
They hit the whole stack.
You hit the top of
the control plane.
You hit the job scheduling.
You hit network programming,
which is crazy complicated,
PD programming, and you
hit the actual data plane
to get the bytes onto the
machine and the machine
to get booted.
And if you can drive
that time down,
it shows technical excellence
throughout the entire stack.
I think it's a really
important metric.
So then I'll show you great
crazy graphs of where our boot
times are today, and
then I'll show you
if you can measure
this yourself,
assuming my laptop
keeps powered.
Lifespan of VMs-- so
today, this is what
you guys do in our cloud today.
This is a CDF.
I should tell you,
actually-- this
is my favorite-- you're going
to see way too many CDFs today.
A CDF shows, at a
given percentile,
what the value of interest is.
So in this case, on
the vertical axis,
it shows you the percentile,
be it 0% to 100%.
And along the
horizontal axis, that
is hours of duration of the VM.
You can see it had a
pretty sharp slope.
And your P50 for all of your
workloads is 12 minutes.
That is the median time of
a VM's life today in GCE.
Pretty short, you would think.
It is pretty short.
And you're doing it
not wrong at all.
I think you're doing
it exactly right.
The entire idea
behind moving to cloud
is that it's incredibly
responsive and agile.
And you can just use--
you can use compute
the second you need it,
and then you discard it, and
it doesn't cost you anything
after that.
This is the exact
right way to use it,
and you're using it right.
And this is what we do
in Google internally.
In Google internally, we're
doing the same thing you are.
And that's when we need compute,
we spin a container up for us.
But we spin up a container,
and then as soon as
that compute is on a
server, we throw it away so
someone else can use it.
And we're down to
six minutes here.
And we actually think that
aspirationally in GCE, we
should drive this
time down even more.
We love to think of--
we think aspirationally
that VM should be thought of
like threats in that you should
be able to spin up a
VM in a sub-second.
That's the whole stack.
And then we throw it away as
soon as you don't need it.
We think this is the future.
We're driving towards it.
But like I said, this
is a full stack problem.
It's moderately hard.
Here's why it's a
full stack problem
and it's moderately hard.
This is from our
internal monitoring.
This shows at a high level--
each one of these lines
shows a large section of code
that is responsible during
a VM boot up bring up.
And if I click on this in
our internal monitoring,
these expand infinitely into
even more subsections that
show-- that are broken down.
But this is the high level view.
And what contributes
to boot times?
It's, of course,
the control plane.
The control plane itself
is incredibly complicated.
It has to do a ton
of business logic.
It has to then do--
in a really weird number
of quota management.
It is strange how many
different quotas are modified
in the construction of a VM.
Then that is sent off to
the actual JobScheduler.
Whoa.
I'm on my demo.
A little early.
Sorry.
Then it goes on to
the JobScheduler.
And the JobScheduler will find
a place, a physical place,
for that VM.
We have, as you know,
custom VM types.
This makes it so we have
a bin packing problem
to solve globally
for the cluster.
Every time you schedule a VM,
we batch it up a little bit
to make it so it isn't
terribly compute intensive.
So we have to find a
physical place for it.
Then once it finds the node, a
lot of containers and cgroups
have to be set up.
There's a lot of computation
that has to happen on the node
to get it ready.
Then in the background, we
start programming the incredibly
complicated virtual networking
while we get the bits onto
the machine as quickly
as possible from--
and we program the remote disk,
and we get the machines onto--
the bits onto the
machine to boot the OS
and run through that.
And then there's a little
bit of overhead for SSH
while we play around with keys
to make it easy for everyone.
But anyway, the total
sum is on the order
of 20 seconds as a P50.
But is there a distribution?
Yes.
Yes, there is a distribution.
These are our four
main geographies.
I'll talk about
that in a second.
You have EU.
You have the US.
You have Asia on here,
each one on a series--
on a CDF.
Again, the CDF
percentile vertical.
Numbering question,
in this term,
is seconds to boot
on the horizontal.
And as you can see, the P50--
if you have your glasses
on-- it's really small.
The P50 is on the order of 20
seconds for both EU and Asia.
And it's a little bit
more, maybe 23 for US.
US is where it
curves a little bit.
That's due to our US zones
being quite a bit larger.
And there's a constant struggle
between the people making
optimizations throughout
that stack and the problems
they get as these cells
get larger and larger.
So there's a constant struggle.
This CDF moves back and forth
continually as the poor devs
struggle mightily.
There is one more.
You'll see there's four lines.
This is an in-house
joke, I'm sure,
where my staff puts Canada
as one of the top GOs
because I'm Canadian.
I am positive.
And they continually
do this to me.
All right.
Let's try a demo.
It's pretty quick, hopefully.
So what this is doing
is this is running PKB.
We're launching on
the order of 20 VMs
simultaneously out
there into the cloud.
These are N1 standard 4s.
And wait-- I'll get
the results page here.
This is from the
previous result.
It will hopefully change
as PKB does its thing.
So we're going to fan
out 20 machines, only 20.
You could do 100.
It's up to you.
But in this case,
we do 20 machines.
We'll record the times.
Some scripts will run to
create a CDF out of this,
and we will see the CDF within
three minutes, approximately.
And most of that time
is spent cleanup.
There's, like, 1.5 minutes
to send out all the machines
and to gather all the data.
And then right now, it
is app get updating.
Oh, it's finished.
It's generating the
graphic at this time.
And now it's going to tear down.
We should have made the teardown
asynchronous and hidden,
but this is what happens
when we make demos.
So we're going to
span out 20 machines
and see if this makes the
previous internal metrics
that we have for how
fast our boot time is.
And hopefully it should finish
tearing down momentarily.
Like I said, PKB is a
moderately large project
that allows us-- this is a
pretty easy script to run.
The graphics-- if
you're really good at R,
it's easy to make the graphics.
That's probably the
hardest part of this.
There are a number
of graphing solutions
if you want to use that.
In this case, like I
said, I want it to be all
self-contained, so we
used R. So anyway--
oh, of course it's already done.
So if I reload this--
oh, god.
All right, that didn't work out.
Let's go here.
There should be a link
that will be updated.
Oh, my.
There you go.
So this is the current CDF.
This is the CDF we just
generated of boot times.
You'll see at P50, amazingly,
it was at 15 seconds.
That's pretty good for us.
This is running Debian
9, which is our best OS.
Of course, boot time
varies on an OS basis,
but this is our best.
All right, back to the slides.
All righty, so compute--
well, this is what you
do with VMs generally,
so incredibly important.
Varies on a couple
of dimensions.
Varies on SKU.
We're going to try N1 versus
C2, see if the C2 is any better.
There's also single-threaded
versus multi-threaded.
This corresponds to SpecInt
versus SpecInt rate.
SpecInt rate is almost
certainly, in almost all cases,
much more important.
But there are a few fringe
cases where SpecInt speed
is more important.
Also, the C2 is even
better at single-threaded,
so I'm going to bring
it up, of course.
I can try to sell my C2s.
And then we're going to talk
about can we do this easier.
We can run SpecInt.
It's the granddaddy.
It's the best.
It's the best metric
overall for doing compute.
But it takes a while.
It's moderately
expensive to run.
Can we get something
like SpecInt results
with some other tool set?
And we'll see if
that's possible.
And then we'll see if we
can measure it ourselves.
I'm not sure I'm going
to run a demo, though.
So it's a little
bit faint, sadly.
I might have to--
I don't know if you can
all see the light green.
There's two lines
here on the CDF.
There is the light
green, which is the N1,
and there is the dark
green, which is the C2.
The C2, spec and speed, the
single-threaded performance
is in this metric on 8 core VMs.
Again, this is not
perfect because we
are in a zone by ourself
while the N1s are living
with a lot of other
people or other customers,
so they're slightly
disadvantaged.
We don't know if this result
will hold once we get to prod.
But right now on single
thread performance,
we're seeing up
to 60% difference
between the N1 and the C2,
which is pretty impressive.
You'll note the CDF for the
C2 actually has a little tail
at the bottom there.
That's not perfect.
It should be perfectly vertical.
We think what happened
here is that I asked
for a lot of samples
from my staff
when we cranked it up to 10
in the little, tiny zone we
had because it's pre-release.
And we think we were making
multiple versions of SpecInt
hit the same socket.
And SpecInt at 8
cores pretty much
saturates the memory
bandwidth of a socket.
So when you get multiple, they
will interfere with each other.
It's a known issue with
SpecInt and normal CPUs.
You run out of memory bandwidth.
It's moderately hungry.
So that 60% lets
you SpecIntRate.
SpecIntRate is, like I
said, much more important
than SpecInt speed
for most uses.
SpecIntRate is multi-threaded.
What is the
throughput of your VM?
These are in N1 standard 8's.
The CDF, again, for--
there's two lines.
I don't know if you can see
it all the way in the back--
one all the way to the right,
one closer to the left.
Again, CDF with
percentiles and numbering
question at the bottom.
And the C2 is doing great.
On this case with N1 standard
8's or C2 standard 8's, we're
seeing up to 50%
difference at P50.
During our press release, we
said 40%, which is very safe,
we think.
We are pretty safe to say
that most of the time,
you will get 40%, at least
40% more performance with a C2
on a per-core basis than
you will with an N2--
with an N1, rather.
So it's a pretty
big jump for us.
I guess I should give a little
bit of data dump on the C2
itself.
It's a Cascade Lake
processor running with--
I don't know if I
should say exactly how
many cores, but substantially
less than we did inside
of the N1.
So therefore, when you go
to NCC versus XEC with Intel
or with any [INAUDIBLE],, having
less cores on a per-chip means
you have way more
TDP per core, and you
will get far higher
clock rates and we do.
Furthermore, we did
a few other things.
The software is slightly
different in the C2,
and the memory is clocked
slightly higher in the C2
than it was in the N1.
And the overall effect is
a tremendous improvement
in performance on
a per-core basis.
All right.
So SpecInt-- like I said,
SpecInt is the granddaddy.
I'm not going to fight SpecInt.
It's, like, 100 PhDs
worked on this for 20 years
to come up with some
random set of benchmarks
with some weighting, and
that is the best, still
the gold standard.
I will always run it.
But is there anything we
can do that could perhaps
be a little bit
cheaper than SpecInt?
Furthermore, SpecInt takes
a couple hours to run--
2, 4, sometimes 24 hours to
run depending on VM size.
And I got a plane to catch.
I can't wait for 24 hours.
I can't do that
with you right here.
We could fork all the tests.
Obviously, SpecInt
is, as you know,
comprised of on the order
of 20 tests, 20 to 30 tests.
We can fork them
all individually,
bring them all back
in, geomean those,
and get a number back out.
But even then, it takes
quite a while to run.
So what about this?
Why don't we try
running stress-ng?
It's a package out there
which has a variety--
maybe 50 different
tests internally.
Geomean all of those together
and see what the result is.
It turns out it's pretty
correlated with SpecInt.
There will be-- in
the GitHub, we'll
give an approximate
correlation coefficient
to see how good stress-ng
is, but it's pretty cheap.
So then we'll take
a look at that.
All right, so let's
see if we can do that.
Let's go to the demo.
But I don't think I'm going
to make you go all the way
through a running of it.
Oh, dear.
And here we go.
This is what the end result is.
I could have hit the button.
If we have time at the end,
I'll hit the button for everyone
so we can the lines slightly
change from left to right.
But we got about 55% difference
in performance between the C2--
or is it 45 in this case--
between the C2 and the N1, which
is within our bounds at P50.
And the CDF looks beautiful.
I love the straight,
vertical CDF.
That's what you want to see in
a CDF-- incredible consistency.
And you're getting a little
more consistency on the C2
that we're running on right
away than we do on the end ones.
And again, that's
almost certainly
due to a couple of factors.
A little bit different
software in the C2 as
compared to the
N1, so we believe
that is going to improve our
performance or consistency.
And using smaller core
counts on a given socket
means you have less probability
of having a neighbor.
So it's pretty great.
Back to the slides.
All right, let's do it live.
I will do it live.
Like I said, I'll do it live
at the end if we have time.
It takes 30 minutes or so.
Memory-- there's a bunch
of great memory tests.
Anyone who's investigated this
finds a bazillion of them.
Multichase, Lmbench is great.
Stream is part of HPCC and
is one of the granddaddies
of memory performance tests.
And there's just a
vast array of these.
We'll be using multichase here
because developed at Google,
and I have to give
my friends props.
So we'll try multichase.
It's generally not as useful
as a stack or compute,
but it can show a few issues.
It can show the NUMA
support of the VMs.
Is it perfect or not?
Are there NUMA
issues underlying?
If you look at the
graph correctly,
and you squint, and
you turn your head,
you can figure out if there's
host, huge page, or giant
or large page support,
like 1 gig or 2 meg pages.
If you really look, you can
probably figure this out.
And so you can also figure out
if there's some weird kernel
KVM host memory manager issues
where locking comes into play.
Because once in a while when
you do a memory benchmark,
you can see some
interesting effect.
And you can figure out if,
way underneath the hood,
there is some kind
of kernel locking
bug that is causing you issues.
We've got a lot of mileage
out of running these tests
over the years, and we
found a number of bugs
throughout our stack
and perhaps in others.
Again, a little bit faint--
I have minimal
control of my staff.
The dark green is the C2.
The light green is the N1.
And this is the
latency of multichase.
So those are in nanoseconds
along the horizontal.
Vertical, of course, as always
in a CDF, is percentile.
What can I say other than
an enormous improvement?
We are talking
about big numbers.
The P50 was about 142
nanoseconds with the N1.
And with the C2, we're
talking about 87 nanoseconds,
which just is about
speed of light
given how virtualization works--
today at least.
And the real improvement
is at the tail.
We had some real tail
issues with the N1
on memory benchmarks.
This was weirdly-- the tails
were not due to memory itself.
They were due to,
interestingly, threads.
So what would happen is you
have a VCPU thread, which
is what backs--
what you think of as
the CPU within your VM.
And once in a while--
because it's really at the
99-point-something up here.
It's really far up.
A user space thread or a kernel
thread would pre-empt you.
And this particular
benchmark is very sensitive.
And it would detect
that, and it would
think that was an incredibly
long memory latency--
a fetch, more precisely--
while instead, it was
just a context switch
underneath the hood.
So with the software
with the C2,
we have been pretty rigorous
in making sure, number one,
every user space thread cannot
interfere with a VCPU thread.
Because there were some that
were interfering periodically.
And furthermore, we have
been working diligently
to move every possible
kernel thread out of the way
and sequester them
away from VCPUs.
That's an ongoing battle.
There will always be a
couple of kernel threads
that can mess you up.
At the P99 point--
I'm going to have
to get this right--
99999 is where
we're shooting for.
So we're going for
seven 9's there.
There will always be a
couple of kernel threads
that can mess you up unless
you do drastic changes.
But we think we have line
of sight to seven 9's.
We're not there yet,
but we're pretty close.
So anyway-- and the other part
of the curve here where we had
problems in the N1 is-- you can
see it's slanted pretty early,
not just the extreme tails--
was NUMA support.
We didn't have good NUMA
support with the N1.
With the N2, the NUMA
support is perfect.
It's not too hard.
We did it right this time.
And it's perfect.
So if memory latency
is crucial to your app,
likely you will be buying a C2.
Demo-- let's do it live.
I'm just going to
show the graph again,
because taking three minutes
probably is not right.
Right on, so if I
just run this-- again,
at the end, if I have an
extra couple of minutes,
we'll run these.
And you can see that
this is exactly the same
as the graph we just ran.
Interestingly--
I should tell you
about how much
these cost to run.
Like I said, I've
been telling you
before it's cheap
to run these tests.
These tests take on the order
of three to four minutes.
This is done with 20 VMs
times 2, so 20 C2s, 20 N1s.
A C2 or an N1 takes costs,
at the smaller sizes,
about $0.10 each.
They're running for on the
order of 1/20 of an hour.
So that's $0.10 per hour.
Multiplied by 40 VMs,
that costs you $0.20.
So it's not overly expensive
to generate this graph.
You can even, if you want,
get a little more fidelity
by cranking up the
number of instances.
If you want the
nice, smooth graphs
we had earlier to 100 or 200,
then it's going to cost you $1.
So these aren't horribly
hard to create on your own,
and it's probably
a good investment.
Back.
All right.
Networking-- oh, we're
blowing through the slides.
I might have time to run
a demo if I have power.
All right.
There are a vast array
of networking tasks.
There is TTCP, and it
has a really long set
of descendants that
have forked and branched
and slightly changed TTCP.
There's iPerf.
Everyone's used iPerf.
It's pretty much a classic.
And it gives very
simple results.
And there's NetPerf.
NetPerf is complicated,
but the author
is pretty cognizant of
just about everything
going on with networking.
This is why it has on the
order of 1,000 switches.
And he works at Google.
He's a friend of mine.
So I'm going to use NetPerf
in the following examples.
But it's a great test.
It's just a little
difficult to run considering
the number of flags.
Again PKB will hide
all the flags for you
and just output a
bunch of samples
that you can throw
through some R scripts
or whatever your
favorite visualizer is.
15 minutes left on my laptop.
And you can then see a CDF.
So networking is
super complicated.
These are snags, they call
them, but just complications.
There's internal
versus external IPs.
Very different performance
characteristics
because the routing is
completely different.
There's rate limiters.
Some clouds have rate
limiters on their networking,
and that completely
changes everything
about how you measure
networking if you
want to see where their rate
limiters work or they kick in.
Distance-- we'll be going with--
distance matters both
at the short scale
within a data center.
So if you can do placement of
machines next to each other,
that actually saves
you a little bit
of time because of the
switches involved, not
due to speed of light.
But also, distance matters then
for how far your data centers
are apart from each
other, because that
will impact replication speed.
And of course, speed of
light matters, and fiber
matters a lot for when
you go across continents.
Oh, and I went
back a second here.
I forgot fabrics vary.
We have built GCE over
the last five years.
Over the five years, we
have revved our fabrics time
and time again.
Some of our older zones have
older fabrics which we then
rev, but it takes time.
So fabrics vary.
And that changes-- that
makes TCP times or latency
vary dramatically.
And finally,
utilization-- utilization
varies on a per-zone basis
because zones are big
and/or small.
And just for some
reason, VMs in some areas
are much more heavily
utilized in others
in terms of networking.
And so you get a slightly
more noisy neighbor effect.
All right, what
does this all look
like with all those caveats?
This is our
intra-zone networking.
As you can see, this
is one line per zone,
and there's a good
amount of difference,
especially the tails
of those zones.
That's normally due to
utilization effects.
But there's also
differences at the P50.
And most of those are
caused by utilization
and by different fabrics.
There's, like,
two-- if you squint,
you can see two giant
bands in the middle there.
And that basically represents
a couple different generations
of network fabric that we use.
We are upgrading all
of our zones commonly.
And the worst ones on here,
if I guess I can say it,
happen to be in Asia 1.
We're upgrading those.
And we assume they will move
slightly more to the left.
Again, sorry.
I should have said what
kind of graph this is.
I hope this is clear by now.
It's a CDF, percent vertical.
Horizontal-- unit of interest,
in this case microseconds.
And P50-- I should
read the slides.
I had notes here.
We're talking-- this
is P50 in most modern--
at P50 we're talking
50 microseconds,
which is pretty reasonable for
ping pong latency, or TCPRR,
as this test is called.
All right.
This is going to be
really hard to see.
I don't know.
I might have to walk down there.
There's a little red line here
if you have your glasses on.
I didn't realize how
thin this would be.
Down here for the C2,
it's a little bit faster
than everything we have today.
This is due to a
couple of reasons.
I don't know if you
all can see that,
but it's a little bit over.
It's at 38
microseconds as opposed
to the rest of our networking.
This is-- why is it
a little bit faster?
A couple of reasons.
One-- obviously, the faster
frequency of the processor
allows it to really blow
through the TCP stack, which
is one of the main
components of latency
when it comes to running TCPRR.
Obviously, if you use MPI and
some fantastic MPI library
that may or may not be released
soon, then that all goes away,
and this time
reduces dramatically.
But with TCP, you
need your processor
to power through that very
complicated TCP receive
function that you can go
take a look in the kernel.
It's hilarious.
Anyway, one of the
things that this
is using-- placement groups.
Placement groups-- or rather,
by happenstance, the C2
was in very low quantity when
we created all these graphs.
And the machines were put very
close to each other physically.
Normally our default cluster
manager configuration is
to spread wide across the entire
cell to make its-- or zone,
sorry in GC parlance--
across the zone to make a
sea of higher reliability.
So you have-- your
null 1 failure
domain will hit two computers.
So this is a little bit
better than it probably
will be for a
computer in real life,
but we think it'll
be pretty good.
We think that we will have
a pretty good product here.
And this will have pretty
solid frequencies--
or rather, TCPRR latencies.
All right.
Between zones,
what can we learn?
Like I said, you can just
run the script again.
There will be a script for
this, and you can generate
these very pretty bands.
You can see, again,
there are two big clumps
for how our clusters
work depending
upon, basically, fabric.
And we have a
policy on distance.
So you're talking
basically 220 microseconds
or 270 microseconds when
you're wanting to go
between zones in GCE over TCP.
It's moderately fast.
Those are our largest
zones and regions.
And then there's the fringe
zones that are a little bit
faster to the right and a
little slower to the left.
The little ones that are
closer to the right, those
are almost always caused by
somewhat considerably smaller
zones.
We have a few zones
like the Montreal zone
that was on an earlier
slide that are very
close to each other physically.
And so they have
incredibly better times.
The times are substantially
better for those.
And again, going all
the way to the left,
there were a few
zones that have tails.
And those are un-upgraded zones.
As I said, Asia is
one of those areas.
Speed of light-- very important
for many applications is
transiting from-- this graph
is really hard to read--
from one GO to another.
And this is all of
our interconnects
between every zone in GCE.
And this is almost entirely--
it's not that interesting
of a slide in that it's
almost entirely generated
from speed of light and fiber
plus a couple of--
how many hops if you
are a little bit
inconsistent in your routing.
But generally, it follows
those numbers almost exactly.
One interesting thing from this
graph is if you can take a look
very carefully--
it's really hard--
about 3/4 of the way up, we
see a slight change in the CDFs
as you--
around 3/4 for a
number of the lines.
This was caused by
a routing glitch
we had in early February--
or last week of February, sorry.
And it got caught.
You too can run these tests--
they're, again,
incredibly inexpensive--
to monitor your cloud and
find out if you lost six
milliseconds-- these are the
milliseconds, by the way,
for your routing--
because of a small
routing glitch.
Well, my battery is dead.
Finally-- I think this is
the final slide for data--
is the networking throughput.
Networking throughput
for GCE is pretty--
compared to other clouds, or
in general, is pretty generous.
We give 2 gigabits
per second per core.
And that is not throttled
in some kind of mechanism.
So that's a lot of--
it's a lot of bandwidth to
give on a per-core basis.
This caps out today.
I don't member our
docs, but I think
I'm safe to say it
caps out at 8 cores.
So 16 gigabits is
where we cap out.
There is a lot of work ongoing
to increase that number.
And in the subsequent
weeks, months,
you should be
seeing announcements
that we have gone considerably
higher on a per-core basis,
so we increased the caps.
But this is where we are today.
And this is the CDF yet
again, percentile vertical.
Horizontal is throughput.
And you can see most of
the time you will get--
on your n1-standard
[INAUDIBLE],, you will get--
and each line is a zone--
you will be getting your
16 gigabits a second.
Once in a while,
it will drop down.
Some zones drop down more
commonly than others.
Again, older
fabrics generally is
where you'll see more of
the issues on the tails.
All right.
Next.
And we can try the demo.
Let's see.
I'm almost at my last
dregs here of power.
And two CDFs-- the C2
and an n1-standard-4.
I don't remember which zone
the n1-standard-4 was in.
You can see the tails
are fantastic on the C2.
This is, again, almost
certainly an artifact,
number one of the high
frequency of the C2,
and secondarily of them being
in close physical proximity.
This is essentially
with placement groups.
Even though it wasn't
a placement group API,
it was that they
happened to be there
because we had very limited
quantities at the time.
But the numbers are fantastic,
38 microseconds, almost a P99,
almost no tails.
We hope that we can deliver
this relatively soon
in large clusters.
Back to the slides.
All right.
Oh, I forgot there's more.
Block devices--
remote block devices
are just like networking in
that they're complicated.
They have all
networking problems,
plus they have media problems.
They are very complicated
to benchmark correctly.
There are many SKUs.
Every cloud has a bunch
of different SKUs.
Every zone is completely
different due to fabric
being different, being due to
the generation of the media
being different.
Cloud is always like this.
We're always buying
different media
as the generations go along,
so there's a little bit
of inconsistency there.
Load-- the media almost
always, or quite commonly, get
slammed, especially
for spinning rust.
But even SSD get
slammed continually
for these remote block devices.
So they're all
very highly subbed.
And so this causes a variance
in many different ways.
And this all varies on a zone,
region, event time basis.
So benchmarking, this
is moderately hard.
Drive sizes modify
the performance,
you'll see, in many complex ways
that are not easily intuited.
Number one-- obviously, we
tell you on the web page,
you'll get this many
IOPS per gigabyte,
and everyone else has
a very similar model.
But furthermore, it turns out
that the internal programming
of these things means that
larger disks have a little bit
more compute necessary to figure
out where to do the LDA to PBA
translations.
And that little bit
more compute makes it
so that they're just
a little bit slower.
So you have to try a
different drive sizes,
and they all have
different characteristics.
So it's just really hard.
And throttling--
the throttling--
because every cloud
has block devices
that are subbed very hard--
they're very hard-- they're
subbed to a very high degree.
They have very complex
throttling mechanisms.
So you have to understand
the throttling mechanisms
that every cloud has
before you benchmark them.
So anyway, that's all
this to say block devices,
sadly, are pretty complicated.
But we can just try random reads
because random reads are easy.
So let's make a device
that's, on this size,
500 gigabytes in size, throw
some random reads against it,
and see what happens.
This is pretty easy.
And it turns out
for us, the bands
are pretty tight, actually.
They're on the order
of 600 microseconds.
And interestingly-- you wouldn't
know this from external,
but I can just say
that's about half
and half in terms of
infrastructure time,
in terms of
networking and media.
And about half of
that is compute.
There is-- like I was
saying, the computation,
if you figure out where
to store the blocks
and how to encode them,
is moderately complicated.
And this is pretty common
across all the clouds,
that that computation
is actually
a large portion of the expense.
And you'll see numbers
around 600 or slightly
around there for most clouds for
4k random reads, the standard.
Random writes-- a little more
random in terms of performance.
You have a couple of
zones that are having--
that obviously
where, in this case,
the media is quite subbed.
And so these are
SSD again where they
are pushing the media hard.
And the media is a little
bit older generation.
But the vast majority is on
the order of 450 microseconds.
You may be wondering, how is
a write faster than a read?
Because I know how SSDs work.
Writes are incredibly hard.
It's because, just
like most drives,
everyone has a little
bit of a cheat.
We have battery-backed computers
that back all of our SSDs.
So we triple write
to three computers
that are battery-backed.
And I was told by
the storage, ATL,
that I actually battery
back at least three times.
We are battery-backed, and
it goes to three machines.
And then when
[INAUDIBLE] is achieved,
then we let you continue.
And then asynchronously,
it is flushed to the media.
In summary, that was
a lot of data slides.
I'm sorry.
But this is what
they pay me for.
Sorry to put you through that.
Cloud is dynamic, and
boot times are really
what power that dynamism.
Please take advantage
of quick boot times.
Use your computers only when
you need them and turn them off.
You'll save lots of
money, and everyone wins.
And you'll push us harder
and harder to be better.
And I like that.
IaaS is complex, but
to a first order,
you can benchmark this pretty
easily and pretty cheaply.
All of those graphs--
like our graphs,
the ones I had that
were in light green--
have more sample points.
But they cost, at most, $100.
And I probably went too crazy
on some of those graphs.
You can make cheaper
graphs for a couple bucks,
and you can get a good
idea of what's going on.
The C2-- we're
pretty happy with it.
So far in all of our
testing, we think
this will be a fine machine.
Please go buy them and make my
capacity planners really upset.
They don't know how they're
going to buy enough so quickly.
And I hope you all go out,
rush out and buy the C2.
It's fantastic.
And most importantly,
don't trust me.
Don't trust anything
you saw here.
These will be easy to run.
Go to that location.
There will be a directory
with demos in it really soon.
I have people working
on finishing the code
and getting it through
code review right now.
So within a few days, there
should be a place there.
And you can just press
up arrow, like I did,
and get numbers, and
maybe believe them.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]